hello and welcome to another video now
today what we are going to be doing is
answering one of the questions that came
through from the video we recorded about
how to develop a language core now the
question I have here is how does one
know if his language core is already
well-established or not and I thought
that was a great question and received a
lot of likes and I assume that there are
many people out there that would like to
know a bit more about this so I'm going
to put this question over to mr. Luo
Calamba diello so how does one know when
if one if his language core is well
established that's a great question it's
also difficult to say to answer this
question well like I would say you feel
it it's very simple the thing is that
when we speak a foreign language for a
while
to the other and we have some kind of
autumn eise's process now talking about
language poor in developing language for
as they said before it means developing
the capacity acquiring the capacity of
assembling pieces together so it's not
so much about just learning fixed
sentences but it's it's about you know
being able to use sentences in different
situations so you know a number of words
but you know how to assemble them
together and I would say that this
happens when you are trying to speak and
first when you're trying to speak it's
easier it means that you can you know
words come automatically we have this
kind of mental lexicon in our brain and
when we speak words come automatically
to us and we can say that I'm expanding
my knowledge now I find that sometime
when I speak Spanish or well just pop
out and I'm like oh I've just I've I've
never used that word before and it just
pops into the right content it's and so
would that be the language core forming
or having pooled means that you've
developed a web and all these words are
just getting attached they get stuck in
the web and it's an another thing so
when speaking and another thing is when
do you remember words very easily it
means that for example there are a lot
of words that are made of the you know
Oh words are made of parts so if you
have developed a certain amount of words
you have acquired a certain amount of
words then you will recognize words even
words that you don't know out of context
but even words that are kind of strange
you remember them because they're made
of parts and you already know
and you remember that very easily so
this is what happened to me for example
in Spanish now every time of your
Spanish word in the minute conversation
or a German word I remembered
immediately while at the beginning to
have problems remembering one of the
things because the language is not yet
set inside of you exactly when these two
things happen happen when you speak or
when you read and listen it means that
your language core is it's like a web
it's exactly like a network or a web and
you know the pieces so fantastic now
thank you that question that question
was really interested in and I hope it
is going to help many of you out there
so the language core you will know it is
developing or has developed when things
start to get a lot easier for you and
when you find that words start popping
out of your mouth in just the right
context and this is a sign or it's a
signal that the language has started to
set inside of your beautiful brain ok so
thank you for watching and we will catch
you in another video
right